[Music]
mushroom prince
can i call you that sure whatever what's
up dope you're gonna
make eye contact do you want to be a
mushroom lord is that better
you didn't seem happy about it there's
already a mushroom yeah mushroom
archbishop
oh mushroom emperor yeah maybe i think
that's just bad
i don't know if i want to take what they
have um
oh i can be a um apprentice
mushroom borrower what's
what about a princess yeah give yourself
something mushroom berry spreader
jester mushroom queen duke mushroom yeah
mushroom oh that's cool that might be
okay like that the princess
i just don't want to be his [ __ ] i want
to be his partner yeah i get it oh it's
oh uh mushroom mushroom queen
okay i'm down with that mushroom queen
that sounds pretty damn
we found the solution there we go let's
go okay so mushroom queen
um i have a story here for you where i'm
really interested
we see that because he has a mushroom
business and that's right in case you're
new
thank you context yes so um
anyway so there's a story here about
this vietnamese doctor
dr mushroom who was looking at his
patients because his patient came in
complaining of pain wow very painful
and very itchy ears oh
guess what he found mushrooms in there
ear finish
growing in his ears growing inside of
his ears how did that happen
is his ear booger that dirty that a
fungus group
how does the mushroom grow mushrooms on
wood businessman on like rotten wood or
wet wood dead wood what produces it
mostly yeah there's fungus or like
what the spores are called mycelium and
then it gets released into the air
and then they fall upon something that
they can
feed upon which is usually wood
as they decompose the wood and they eat
the bud the wood
uh is the nutrients and then the
mushrooms grow
so it's like a parasite it eats off of
the wood it's like bacteria
yeah it's fungus it's okay but it feeds
so if this cat's walking by while
while these mushroom spores are released
and he collects them in his ear
and he keeps wetting his ear like we do
our logs because we all have mushroom
logs from the mushroom cake guess it
kind of works that way
maybe it goes to the sauna a lot he has
to keep the humidity up though
because we all know that you have to
have a little humidifier thing in there
yes
in vietnam very humid see so there you
go
yeah that could be so really to
mushroomfarm.com
oh yeah check it out
mushroomkingform.com is there a code to
get a discount
not right now cool awesome
yeah so the doctor he examined his
patient with the endoscope
and found two centimeter long
fungi whoa look at gnocchi
just above his eardrums and i have a
video is he like
itchy like my ear is so itch man i don't
know what the hell happened
yep he goes god damn you got a [ __ ]
mushroom in there man
there's not much room in your ears look
at this
oh wait what look at these guys holy
[ __ ] dude
that's gross i don't know that's
mushrooms oh my god
how did that even [ __ ] what's wrong
in there
that is crazy you told me that's a cave
with ivy i believe you oh my god
that has to be like a documented sign
look at this [ __ ]
little heads the little mushrooms insane
how did that even happen
you could also tell me oh casey oh god
because i know you would so it made me
want to throw up because someone said it
was good
if someone tried it first yeah but i
don't think it's like edible dude i
don't think it's that kind of mushroom
you could tell me that's a [ __ ] colon
by the way and i believe you true it
does look like a colony
it's so weird how those things can just
like
grow in uh body parts and uh
does that make you think differently
about mushrooms for some reason this is
worse to me
than seeing bugs and ears really yeah
yes yeah i agree
that's worse right well mushrooms like
the the trippy ones they grow on
dookie right so is maybe your ear wax
kind of like
ear dookie that's not the only way they
grow i can tell you how this doctor
thinks the
patient got how did he get [ __ ] in
here close
what happened you're close to getting
[ __ ] in the ear
yeah close oh my god so patient had
likely transferred the fungi
into his ear after sharing ear hygiene
equipment with others uh why the [ __ ]
would you share a q-tip
hey doc you gonna finish that or like
those little holdings
okay okay thank you how did this other
homie get mushrooms in his ears
i don't know or maybe it was like spores
in the air when they were transferring
or something
that's my theory wow that's crazy
you couldn't just use one of those ear
douches have you seen those ear douches
i like those it's like a blue squeeze
bottle you put water in and you squeeze
and then you suck it all up yeah have
you done a neti pot
yeah i love those i love my nose those
are great i don't know if is it the
similar it sounds like it but i don't
know because it doesn't come out the
other year it doesn't come out
[Laughter]
it's like the cartoon because you know
the neti bot it comes out the other
notes
if you fail an iq test it should come
out the other because there's nothing
there
empty i have seen other people too use
like
some sort of like candle thing they like
they say that's kind of [ __ ]
yeah i heard that it's not good for you
or something yeah but i've seen that
in asia they have those ear scoopers
yeah that's what i was thinking you get
that service done in vietnam so it might
be
they didn't clean the tools like you can
get your ear picked there
oh [ __ ] you pace i was gonna go do it
but i didn't do it but i heard it
you get a professional to stick a thing
up your ear to clean it well have you
seen those
asian like ear diggers yeah my my
grandpa has a hole at one end it's like
a soft little cotton ball
and then oh man my mom used to hook me
up with those i would be a little
tested i need it it goes in there and it
feels amazing
how do you know what you're doing like
what are you doing you kind of feel
around and you scoop
is it only for wet i mean uh dry
your way i have dry ear wax so i have
wet ear wax yeah i don't know if it'll
work for me
i feel like bragging feels amazing
[Laughter]
yeah they just dig and dig and dig and
pick it up yeah that's all it is
yeah q-tips feel amazing yeah i stick to
q-tips even though apparently you're not
imagine a back scratcher but the size of
a small
little scooper right it's like that and
then they put it in your ear and then
they dig around and they that's exactly
what it looks like yeah and then they
dig
around and then they pull it out and you
get [ __ ] boogers man it's huge
they shovel out gold so is this cat
pulling cultures out of his ear like
what's going on oh
well he's harvesting is what he's doing
harvesting mushrooms
yeah the doctor did remove the fungi
and um he just said that he'll be in
pain for a couple days and
he'll be fine you know what i don't like
about um i think
why we cringe because fungus and
infection
you know it's the same thing like they
labeled it as a
fungal ear infection yeah yeah it's like
a wart
fungus ugh it's just weird that there's
a [ __ ] mushroom going on yeah
even if it wasn't like it was a plant
it's just weird yeah but what if it was
beautiful like coral yeah we should
normalize this
oh yeah there we go we're not thinking
about this one now it's just for this
one guy
come on we should normalize it no some
mushrooms look dope man
some of them look like ornaments and
[ __ ] oh the the red one with the dots
i love those ones you eat that when you
get bigger that's true
alice in wonderland kind of mushrooms
don't eat the kids though
what happens the magic mushrooms if you
eat the yellow mushrooms kid you get an
extra life
so that's stupid the green one that's a
level up
that's pretty good all edible like all
emotionally fine the
woods are edible you just said they're
poisonous no that one specifically
no don't do it that one you find in
yours there uh have you heard of um
[ __ ] i think i forgot the name of it but
there's this whole thing where people go
into nature
and then foraging foraging and they grab
[ __ ] and they just [ __ ] eat that
cam was really getting into that for a
minute and i was like man how do you
know which ones to get
because i don't want to be the guy
that's like oh it looks like that
mushroom and then you pick it you eat it
and you die
well people read books about it first
right yeah you don't just know so
because there's like uh biological is
that what it's called the people that
study the psychologists yeah so there's
mycologists on tiktok and they're like
clowning not climbing but trying to
teach other people because there's other
ones that claim to be
and they're like oh this is an edible
one and they're like it's edible like
you could eat it but you're gonna have
really bad stomach problems and you die
that's too much you could die
and then it's like do not eat this one
right and then
they're like it looks like this one but
you could tell by these key differences
yeah
that's a cool like knowledge thing
but i do want to know like any terrain
or or
for example like um if i walk into the
desert here what can i eat when i can't
i don't know they all just look like
plants and bugs
when i was a kid in indianapolis i
remember
my parents they had a mint uh like
little
what do you call it plant garden plant
yeah and so i remember
my mom would just take leaves off of it
we'd all eat the mint leaves and it was
like cool
and then we moved to virginia and i saw
a planter box in my neighborhood
that had something similar to that and
so i just picked
like the leaf and i was eating it like
it doesn't taste very minty and i went
back to my mom
and i was like hey i tried this it's not
very minty though these mint plants suck
in virginia
and i was like stephen what did you eat
oh my god what is that
my parents went nuts they pulled out
something called the merck manual
which has every [ __ ] plant and what's
poisonous not poisonous
and they're going through it and they're
like freaking out what should we do my
mom calls my dad at worst like what are
we gonna do
and it turns out i just ate something
that doesn't matter like a four-leaf
clover yeah yeah it's like some stupid
[ __ ]
just got good luck yeah but i was i was
lucky enough it didn't [ __ ] me over but
like you know
you were associated i should have bought
bitcoin back then i should have
that's what i was trying to hear that no
but but when you associate like
picking up plants is yeah like with just
being a kid you just think that
everything you gotta educate them
because they're stupid
you think it's [ __ ] willy wonka
you're like licking the wallet
that's true because i remember when i
was a kid with my cousin
so we would at her house her dad had
like a garden and he had like a
blueberry tree
or like blackberries yeah no yeah not
blueberry blackberries
and so we would pick them all the time
and then she would tell me she was like
four or five years younger than me
but she would tell me like oh these on
like by the grass like these four leaf
clover looking ones
these taste sour they taste so good so
i'd be sitting there with her me older
than her [ __ ] eating
the [ __ ] clothes [ __ ] from the grass
and they were really good
really but i'm like i'm like i don't
know is that like
i could have died like what the [ __ ] was
it blueberries or blackberries i don't
know so the tree was
like a blackberry okay or at least for
me because i was so little looked like a
tree maybe it was just a bush i don't
know
but the point is did it have an owl that
comes out of a hog
no no it wasn't an actual tree oh but
but yeah the point is that like
by that tree it like in the grass area
there was like four-leaf clover [ __ ] and
we would be eating off of that well
that's how we kind of know what to eat
and whatnot
those people die people die yeah [ __ ]
yeah would you like
those guys hey we just found this new
plant uh hey
victor you take it take a shot see what
happens it starts [ __ ] his braids up oh
[ __ ] was it good the the clover i'm
telling you it was it was bomb it was
sour
and i'm mexican i love sour [ __ ] so
would you like it
did you put tahini on it it didn't exist
there's a lot of people
but did you guys buy bitcoin though
[Music]
do